the juror experience what is your
perspective on the big bang
there's a lot of people's views
vary depending upon like what what the
most recent theories are
and yeah but some people believe that
the universe started with the big bang
and some people believe that it's always
existed and there's it's a continuing
cycle of big bangs endless expansion
and then ultimately contraction and then
it starts all over again
and that there's infinite numbers of big
bangs that are occurring through
multiverses
right various universes all over the
world all over the the
the cosmos right so i'm reading this
book right now called the end of
everything by a friend of mine katie
mack wrote it it's about the end of the
universe
and it's really cool it talks about
exactly what you're saying so there was
a big bang you can see it actually in
the cosmic background
radiation there's this microwave and
isotropy it's like
everything's not uniform and you can see
that it's like two or three degrees
kelvin it's really cold
so the question is does it does it
explode and then does it
shri the big crunch you know does it
come back and
they think there's a stuff called dark
energy so does it continue expanding
and she calls it heat decay or this
other one's the big rip where it just
keeps on expanding accelerating and
like even electrons can everything just
disintegrates into nothing
and no one knows what's going to happen
but the really cool thing i was just
reading the chapter about
as it expands super fast
i forgot the name of it boltzmann's
brain or something there's some weird
thing where
because of quantum physics which is
completely
not understandable if you say you
understand quantum mechanics you don't
things can just randomly appear so if
you're
if the universe is going to be around
for trillions of years
like in theory at some point
two trillion years from now joe rogan
could just suddenly
create itself out of nothing in the
universe and you'd like look around and
go wow what's going on and then you
disappear instantly because of quantum
mechanics
so it's it's a really what yeah it's
explained again
so the the theory is you could have an
entire universe just
because of quantum mechanics which is uh
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
right you don't you can't know
position and velocity you can only know
one or the other
and an extension of that again man i'm
just a fighter pilot i'm not a physicist
but you can
things can just suddenly appear
somewhere and so
given enough time even though it's
highly unlikely
this water bottle could create itself
out of nothing just because of physics
quantum mechanics i remember my teacher
at the air force academy would use the
example of
all of the electrons and protons and
stuff could suddenly
move themselves and you could just fall
through the floor
now the odds of that happening it ain't
going to happen in for a trillion years
but these weird things can happen and so
she she uses this kind of cheeky
funny example of you know your brain
could just suddenly create itself out of
nothing and given enough time the
probability would
would be that so some people say the
whole universe is just this temporary
thing that created itself but
i don't know it's very disconcerting
when you hear them talk about quantum
mechanics
that is you know what i figured
relativity
you start going wait what exactly two
things can exist simultaneously in
different places
and one of them could be in motion the
other one could be still and they're the
same thing
and they appear and disappear and yeah
what and now there's quantum computers
yeah that's weird yeah do you understand
that no
i don't think no i i spoke at a
conference
and i followed the quantum computing guy
so um
it's cool stuff right you know i've had
guys like sean carroll try to explain it
to me on the podcast
it just goes in one of my chimp ears
[Laughter]
you and me both man like i said i'm a
fight i love it it's cool to learn about
it but um
it it does make things
seem a lot more mystical
than um just the standard
sort of newtonian physics perspective
of life and gravity and matter and
yeah carbon-based life forms when you
when you start getting into just
listening to what they're talking about
when they're talking about quantum
weirdness and entanglements and
things in superposition you're like wait
what is the world made of
right like can you get down to the
smallest
possible measurement of life
the smallest things that you can measure
the world becomes magic
yeah on the smallest scale and also on
the biggest scale
right well that's the weirdest part
about the universe
is that i'm inclined especially as i get
older and i think about things more
to think that everything is kind of
fractal
and what the universe is probably is
it's probably a part of some other
organism
some immense organism that's in a
universe that's impossible for us to
comprehend right the vastness of it
when you know there's a thing they just
did recently where they mapped out
uh the human uh they're talking about
human brain cells
and the universe and they were talking
about the way the universe functions and
the universe functions the way it looks
like if you do a scan of the universe
right like it looks far too similar
right to a human brain cell
this is a talk i want to do joe so i saw
these patterns from space
there's this one picture of a river in
indonesia i took it it looks like
arteries like all these blood vessels
coming out
and i remember thinking there's all
these patterns that repeat
the seashells there's these spiral
elliptical seashells
and then there's hurricanes yeah and
then there's galaxies
yeah and these these patterns repeat
from the microscopic
to the macroscopic it's really cool it's
amazing yeah and i don't understand them
all but
they in images they're really cool have
you ever seen
videos on fractals where they show you
things like the mandelbrot set
and how the the closer you get to these
fractals the same sort of pattern
repeats itself
over and over and over again and when
people it is one thing to
comprehend if someone's explaining it to
you in a lecture but there's another
thing now with the advent of cgi
technology you can see
these fractals be repeated over and over
and over again
right and the mandelbrot set is a
particularly interesting one because
it's so beautiful and weird
and uh each each part of that as they go
deeper
see if you can find a video on it
because it's pretty badass mandelbrot
set
fractal demonstration um i know it's on
youtube
but that these these patterns if the
universe really is
a part of an atom that's in a being
right
or a part of a cell that's in a being
that exists
in a and you know the idea of infinity
too right
we think of the universe as being
massive it's 14 billion like that's not
infinite right it's not even close right
14 billion years
is like nothing it's not infinite at all
um so this is the mandelbrot set right
oh cool and so
what these artists have done is as they
zoom in the mandelbrot set repeats
itself over and over and over and over
again
and it just it becomes the same exact
thing
at the the lowest possible levels of uh
of of comprehension or of illustration
they keep getting closer and closer to
it
that's amazing yeah i needed that i was
a math major in college
and i learned about fractals but they
didn't have videos back then right to
this video
well this this would blow you away right
because it shows it to you
that in a way that appeals to the brain
right
and it's it's so hard for us to
comprehend or to
try to illustrate it ourself this is the
kind of [ __ ] that you see when you're on
psychedelic drugs too
this is another reason why it makes
people wear the mushroom yeah yeah
like if you go on a super trip like a
real trip where you can't come back
for four or five hours this is the kind
of [ __ ] that you'll see
and it makes you wonder like are you
looking at the
the very fabric of the cosmos itself
so i think there's a theory string
theory is kind of
popular for small stuff what electrons
are made out of in the smallest
sub-atomic level
and if i remember right 10 to the minus
33rd meters which is pretty small
but i think that's as small as you can
get like there's a there's a
there is a smallest particle you can't
just keep on going
infinitely smaller just like you can't
go infinitely bigger because the
universe is only so big
so there it is bounded that can't happen
forever um
which is which is pretty well allegedly
but you know right but
you know 10 years from now everything we
think we know is going to be disproven
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience